à l'étranger la Birmanie ou l'opposition
à former un gouvernement provisoire
contre le régiment place l'Arménie
soviétique encore ou plus de 100000
personnes ont à nouveau manifesté dans
les rues des reines enfin la Tunisie où
nous allons retrouver nos envoyer
spéciaux pierre serra Nicolas Jacobs
Jean-François Hoffman il s'agit d'un
éclairage sur la Tunisie de la pré
Bourguiba une page spéciale que vous
allez nous présenter au Briel
Aubry Adler
bonsoir nous sommes ce soir à Tunis pour
une édition spéciale consacrée à la
Tunisie de Ben Ali dis-moi après la
destitution du président Bourguiba le
nouveau chef de l'État nous a accordé
une première interview exclusive s'il a
semble-t-il apaisé la population il n'a
pas encore réussi à juguler la crise
économique chômage hausse des prix
rejoint cette année par la sécheresse
tempête aujourd'hui l'espoir née du
changement dans le pays le président Ben
Ali qui nous a reçu pierre Serrat et moi
a accepté tout d'abord d'expliquer les
conditions de son arrivée au pouvoir
monsieur le Président bonsoir vous êtes
au pouvoir depuis novembre dernier vous
aviez alors estimé qu'il était
nécessaire de destituer le président
Bourguiba alors qu'avez-vous fait pour
la Tunisie depuis
d'abord
c'est pas une destitution il s'agissait
d'un acte de redressement
salut national vous savez avant le 7
novembre
la loi était bafouée des institutions
et je devais bien entendu
rétablir l'état de droit
et j'ai fait
ce que
je dois faire c'est à dire
répondre à l'appel de devoir
et à l'attente populaire et cet effet
dans stricte respect de la Constitution
et de la loi sont sans égoutte de sang
et son amour
le vrai premier service que vous avez
rendu à la Tunisie c'est dans somme
d'enlever Bourguiba qui était au pouvoir
depuis 30 ans qui était malade j'étais
malade il était pas
dans un état de gouverner le pays
n'était pas gouverné il était un
gouvernable il était à peine administrer
le président a été effectivement malade
et il avait un entourage néfaste
précisément lorsque vous avez été nommé
Premier ministre en octobre le 12
octobre 87 est-ce que le problème de la
destitution se posait déjà pour vous à
ce moment-là
le problème se posait moi j'ai vécu avec
le président Bourguiba depuis 94 et donc
j'ai côtoyé le Président j'ai le côtoyé
tous les matins de 7h à 10h et j'ai vu
le président Bourguiba dans quel état il
était il était incapable de gouverner
sur cette décision
qu'il prenait la veille
donc il était pas dans un état normal
était malade il était dans un état de
santé vraiment qui l'empêche de
gouverner et aujourd'hui convaincu
maintenant enfin comment il va comment
les vieux comme quelqu'un qui a plus de
80 ans
vous les évoquez tout à l'heure des
élections sont normalement prévues dans
quelques semaines en Tunisie lors
sont-elles d'abord destinées à asseoir
votre légitimité
enfin la légitimité on l'a vu
depuis le 7 novembre il y a eu
beaucoup de manifestations
cette période donc là je l'ai je l'ai de
par la Constitution
ça veut dire que quand tu as les
élections présidentielles la prochaine
fois on a vu aujourd'hui que vous avez
ici élaboré un pacte national avec les
parties d'opposition il y aura donc pas
un candidat unique à la présidence de la
République
c'est ouvert à toutes les sensibilités
du pays
an vous êtes général vous l'avez dit
vous-même tout à l'heure plusieurs de
vos ministres au moins deux sont
également des officiers est-ce que cela
signifie pour la première fois de son
histoire en Tunisie l'armée de pouvoir
des grands chefs d'État dans les grandes
démocraties étaient bien d'origine
militaire et l'origine la chef d'État le
détermine pas son profil oui jugé
ces actions son programme
alors cette Tunisie nouvelle donc vous
avez l'ambition vous semblez la vouloir
davantage intégrer au monde arabe que
tourner vers l'Europe musulmane
nous avons avec
les pays du grand Maghreb
nous avons engagé un processus pour
l'éducation
voilà
pour la ce qui
ouvert modernisme
il y avait effectivement un problème
avant avant le 7 novembre
problème du comportement
officiel officiel
peut respecter la religion
donc nous avons pris certains mesures
pour rendre l'islam la place qui nous
revient dans un pays musulman d'une part
d'autre part
j'ai affirmé à plusieurs reprises dans
mes discours que la Tunisie appartient à
tous ses enfants sans exclusive c'est
peut-être ça qui est un peu les esprits